bonsoir merci de votre invitation alors
effectivement les discussions du sommet
de genève de ce vendredi 21 janvier ont
découlé sur la situation suivante à
savoir un statu quo et la fédération de
russie a formulé la volonté que l'otan
on retire ses troupes de roumanie et de
bulgarie chose qui ait une demande à
laquelle les les autorités bulgares
roumaines n'accèdent pas l'otan refusent
pour autant la question de savoir si une
invasion est imminente je pense qu'il
faut faut garder la tête froide par
rapport à cette situation aujourd'hui la
russie a beaucoup à perdre si elle
venait à envahir l'ukraine ça serait
quelque chose une opération beaucoup
trop coûteuse pour elle politiquement
sur le plan interne ça ce cas aussi
quelque chose d'assez difficile à faire
admettre les autorités ukrainiennes dans
les régions frontalières
elles sont également préparées elles ont
l'expérience des années précédentes est
la situation aujourd'hui n'est pas si
simple pour la fédération de russie est
aujourd'hui les autorités américaines
cherchent aussi à mettre la pression sur
ces aspects là pour faire comprendre aux
autorités russes qu'elles ont beaucoup à
perdre justement du côté des occidentaux
on a déjà tout va commencer à livrer des
armes à l'ukraine l'allemagne elle s'y
refuse pour l'instant estime que ça ne
permettrait pas de désamorcer la crise
comment expliquer cette position des
allemands qui détonne avec celle des
américains et des
britanniques notamment
écouter on est dans le langage
diplomatique
on est dans un rapport de force qui est
engagée certains états ont davantage
intérêt à
montrer les muscles les le royaume uni
l'a fait les pays baltes honte à nous
c'est l'estonie la lettonie et la
lituanie ont annoncé ce vendredi qu'elle
allait procéder à l'envoi de missiles
antichars et antiaériens en ukraine
l'allemagne est davantage réservé sur
sur ce type d'opération parce qu'elle
est engagée dans d'autres négociations
avec la fédération de russie sur
d'autres dossiers notamment sur sur les
questions
de géopolitique du gaz qu'est-ce qu'il
faut attendre des discussions qui vont
reprendre la semaine prochaine
et goûter à ce stade il est difficile de
faire des projections l'histoire récents
nous conduite à dire considérer que que
tout est possible comme je vous le
disais des autorités américaines ne
doivent réfléchir aux moyens de pression
qu'elles peuvent faire sur moscou
elles doivent dissuader moscou pour une
désescalade et paradoxalement la
désescalade va passer par une escalade
c'est-à-dire par l'envoi d'armes de
défense comme on le disait par
l'intermédiaire du royaume uni par
l'intermédiaire des pays baltes mais
aussi la russie test test l'otan test
l'union européenne elle teste les états
unis pour savoir jusqu'où
ces parties là peuvent aller elles
formulent des demandes inacceptables
comme comme le retrait des troupes de
roumanie de bulgarie
elles savent que cette demande là sera
inaccessible mais elle espère que du
lest sera lâchée sur d'autres points par
exemple
elle chercha à pouvoir faire des
invasions dit crête dans le donbass pour
consolider des acquis on est dans un an
lorsque dans ce qu'on appelle dans ce
qu'on appelait à l'époque de l'urss la
stratégie du salami comme l'a rappelé
récemment dominique moïsi c'est à dire
que chaque jour on coupe une tranche
fine et à force de couper une tranche
fine à la fin il ya plus de salami